en 2014 80000 moteurs sont sortis de
l'usiné john deere située au nord
d'orléans une année faste pour le leader
français de fabrication de matériel
agricole
l'entreprise a même dû embaucher près de
300 intérimaires pour pallier aux pics
d'activité mais depuis le début de
l'année le site est confrontée à une
chute brutale des ventes de tracteurs
moins 40% de nouvelles immatriculations
dans la région - 25 % au niveau national
une baisse qui s'explique notamment par
le plongeon du coût des matières
premières et donc des revenus des
agriculteurs
nous avons eu jusqu'à l'heure où nous
parlons uniquement trois jours
d'activité partielle donc ça reste
relativement limitée et les perspectives
que nous avons pour la fin de cette
année et surtout pour les années à venir
ne doit pas nous amener à voir d'autres
d'autres jours d'activité partielle et
nous avons je dirais actuellement sur
nos sur nos tablettes vraiment un plan
de travail sur les sur les cinq
prochaines années ou l'année 2016
s'annonce comme une année de transition
et nous devrions retrouver un niveau
d'activité que je qualifierais de normal
sur l'exercice 2010 est l'optimisme du
président de john deere france est
partagée à l'autre bout de la chaîne par
les concessionnaires de machines
agricoles
en un an ils ont vu leur chiffre
d'affaires fondre de 20 à 30%
mais pour pascal cornet le métier est
cyclique il faut savoir s'adapter on
vend plus de services et notre
profession est dévolu sur les modèles où
on va vendre plus peut-être vendre ou
pas avant demain on va au moins essayer
de faire quelque chose avec de la
formation avec
de l'entretien avec un certain nombre de
choses de la location mais
on va évoluer depuis une quinzaine
d'années l'union européenne a mis en
place un certain nombre de normes pour
rendre les moteurs moins polluants
des mesures qui avait jusqu'ici
contribué à maintenir l'activité
aujourd'hui constructeurs et
distributeurs attendent de nouvelles
restrictions pour relancer le marché